choose a Riverdale plot line that sounds
fake but it's totally real
oh cold love this when Betty found out
she had serial killer Gene when Archie
got mauled by a bear when Jughead
delivered his I'm a weirdo speech out of
the blue when Cheryl waterboarded her
mother with maple syrup oh God when
Edgar ever and ever and his Oregon
harvesting for joined the fold when
Veronica rounded underground speak
easily well I was actually in Vancouver
when Archie got mauled by a bear it was
really funny to be there for that but
when Cheryl water waterboarded her
mother with maple syrup is the most
extremely bizarre thing I've ever read